>>> JUST MOMENTS AGO IN MOSCOW,
A MAJOR ESCALATION IN RUSSIA'S
WAR, VLADIMIR PUTIN IMMEDIATELY
ANNEXING RUSSIAN TERRITORIES,
AGAIN ILLEGALLY.
IT'S A MOVE THAT WORLD LEADERS
SAY WILL NOT BE ACKNOWLEDGED.
JOINING ME IS MATTHEW CHANCE AND
NICK PAYTON WALSH.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS WE HAD
SEEN THAT RAPID SPEED
COUNTEROFFENSIVE BY THE
UKRAINIANS TO AVOID JUST THIS
EARLIER THIS MONTH.
ALL OF THAT HAVING BEEN SAID,
VLADIMIR PUTIN DOUBLES DOWN AND
FOLLOWS UP ON THIS ANNEXATION.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
>> IT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE OF THAT
RAPID ADVANCE BY UKRAINIAN
FORCES ON THE GROUND, WHICH NICK
WILL TALK TO YOU ABOUT IN A
MINUTE THAT PUTIN HAS BROUGHT
FORWARD THIS REFERENDUM TO
INTERNATIONAL OBSERVERS AS WELL
THAT HE IS GOING TO DO THIS,
HE'S DETERMINED TO DO IT,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT HE DOESN'T
CONTROL VAST AREAS OF TERRITORY
THAT HE'S ABOUT TO ANNEX.
HE'S NOW MADE THIS SPEECH IN
MOSCOW, THE NEXT STEP IN
FORMALLY ANNEXING THESE
TERRITORIES.
HE SAID THEY'RE NOW FOUR NEW
REGIONS OF RUSSIA AND CALLED ON
KYIV TO COME BACK TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE AND MADE IT
CLEAR THAT EVEN THOUGH RUSSIA
WAS LOOKING FOR A PEACE DEAL,
THESE REGIONS WOULD NOT BE UP
FOR NEGOTIATION.
HE SAID THAT THESE PEOPLE WILL
BE IN RUSSIA FOREVER, I'M
PARAPHRASING IT HERE.
HE HAS DRAWN RUSSIAN'S RED LINE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAS DECLARED HE WILL DEFEND
THESE TERRITORIES AS THEY ARE OF
MOTHER RUSSIA, INCLUDING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, AS NECESSARY.
>> I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THE COUNTER DEFENSIVE.
WE HAVE PUTIN LYING TO THE
PUBLIC AND LYING TO THE WORLD
SAYING THIS IS NOW PART OF
MOTHER RUSSIA.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAID SINCE
DAY ONE, IF THERE'S A
REFERENDUM, AN ANNEXATION, THERE
IS NO TURNING BACK, HE'S NOT
GOING TO THE NEGOTIATION TABLE.
SO WHAT HAPPENS NEXT IN TERMS OF
ANY POSSIBLE TALKS BETWEEN THESE
TWO SIDES?
>> Reporter: I THINK THAT
PROSPECT IS PRETTY REMOTE.
THIS SEEMS TO BE THE KREMLIN'S
BIG PLAY HERE, AGAIN PAINTING
RUSSIA HAS A VICTIM.
HE'S ESSENTIALLY SAYING LET'S
HAVE A UNILATERAL CEASE-FIRE AND
STOP FIGHTING AND GO TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
RUSSIA HAS USED DIPLOMACY TO
PURSUE ITS POLITICAL OBJECTIVES.
HE SEEMS TO BE HOLDING THAT OUT
HERE WITH THE BACKGROUND THREAT
YOU JUST HEARD OF POSSIBLE
NUCLEAR FORCE, SOMETHING THAT OF
COURSE EVERYONE SHOULD TREAT AS
REMOTE AND THE LAST HORRIFYING
IDEA BUT IN THE BACKGROUND
DURING ALL OF THIS.
LOOKING AT THE CROWD AFTER SOME
OF THAT SPEECH, THERE WEREN'T
THAT MANY CONVINCED FACES.
ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE AS
RUSSIA ANNOUNCES THESE NEW AREAS
OF ITS TERRITORY, PARTS THAT
UKRAINE CONTROLS IS GROWING HOUR
BY HOUR.
ONE OF THE FOUR REGIONS WHICH
THEY SAY IS PART OF RUSSIA THEY
ARE ON THE VERGE WHICH HAS
THOUSANDS OF RUSSIA'S BEST
TROOPS IN IT IS CLOSE TO BE
ENCIRCLED BY A VERY RAPID
UKRAINIAN ADVANCE.
WE'VE SEEN HOW IT BURST THROUGH
THE COUNTRYSIDE HERE IN THE PAST
WEEKS.
IT'S CONTINUING AROUND OTHERS
AROUND LIUHANSK.
IT'S ON THE GROUND BEING
DISMANTLED SLOWLY HOUR BY HOUR
AND SOME ARE SEEING THIS
ENCIRCLEMENT AS THE POSSIBILITY
OF YET ANOTHER RUSSIAN COLLAPSE
LIKE WE SAW IN KHARKIV.
SUPPLY LINES WERE HIT, THE
RUSSIAN ARMY RAN.
THAT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE HERE.
PUTIN IS GIVING US THIS
EXTRAORDINARY VISION OF A RUSSIA
UNDER THREAT THAT IT IS NOW
DECLARING ITS TERRITORY EXPANDED
BUT AT THE SAME TIME ITS
CONVENTIONAL FORCES HAVE BEEN
FAILING HERE FOR WEEKS, HE HAS
SUCCEEDED IN SENDING OVER
200,000 OUT OF RUSSIA TO AVOID
IT BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN TENS OF
THOUSANDS PROPERLY EQUIPPED
SOLDIERS HERE.
WE'RE IN A DANGEROUS MOMENT
WHERE RUSSIA SEEMS TO HAVE
PLAYED ITS CARD SAID THESE ARE
NOW PARTS OF RUSSIA, DO NOT
TOUCH THEM OR WE RESERVE OUR
RIGHT TO DEFEND THEM.
IT'S CALLED FOR MORE DIPLOMACY
BUT THAT IS LIKELY TO BE
REJECTED AND WE'RE LEFT FOR
MOMENTS WHERE UKRAINE CONTINUES
TO GO FORWARD BECAUSE RUSSIA
DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE
CONVENTIONAL FORCES THERE TO
CHANGE THINGS.
>> THAT ROOM, IT LOOKS ANYTHING
BUT CELEBRATORY.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A DAY OF
JUBILATION THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO
COPY WHAT HAPPENED IN 2014 WHEN
HE ANNEXED CRIMEA.
CLEARLY THE SITUATION IS
DIFFERENT RIGHT NOW, A RARE
ADMISSION OF MISTAKES BEING MADE
YESTERDAY THAT STRUCK ME IN
TERMS OF THE PARTIAL
MOBILIZATION OF TROOPS IN
RUSSIA.
AND YOU'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AS WE JUST HEARD THAT
MANY, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
PERHAPS, OF MEN HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO LEAVE BECAUSE THERE IS
CONCERN OF JUST ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF MEN WHO HAVE BEEN CALLED UP
TO ARE DUTY.
>> YEAH, LOOK, THIS WHOLE
ADVENTURE FROM THE KREMLIN'S
POINT OF VIEW HAS BEEN MISSTEP
AFTER MISSTEP.
IT'S JUST INCREDIBLE LOOKING AT
THE FACES AT THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN THIS FACILITY AS VLADIMIR
PUTIN GIVES THIS SPEECH, WHICH
IS MEANT TO, AS YOU SAY, A
CELEBRATION OF THE HOME COCOMIN
LOCAL PARTS OF RUSSIA.
EVERYONE HAS A BLANC EXPRESSION
ON THEIR FACE BECAUSE THEY KNOW
WHAT THE COST HAS BEEN SO FAR TO
THE COUNTRY AND WHAT IT GOING TO
BE.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID AND IT
WAS ALMOST UNBELIEVABLE, HE WAS
LIKE WE'RE GOING TO REBUILD THE
DESTROYED CITIES AND MAKE THESE
REGIONS PROSPEROUS AGAIN AND
THERE WASN'T A GLIMMER OF
AGREEMENT ON THOSE PEOPLE'S
FACES.
THEY ARE SITTING THERE BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN TOLD TO SIT THERE
AND NOD THEIR HEADS.
>> THESE ARE SOME OF.
POOREST REGIONS OF UKRAINE AS
WELL, ESPECIALLY DONBAS.
>> THEY'RE INDUSTRIAL REGIONS
AND THEY'VE GOT POTENTIAL BUT
THEY'VE BEEN DEVASTATED AND LAID
TO WASTE THE LAST MONTHS.
>> WE SHOULDN'T LOOK LIGHTLY ON
THAT NUCLEAR THREAT HE CONTINUES
TO DANGLE.
HOPEFULLY WE WON'T SEE THAT DAY.
IT'S A CAUSE OF CONCERN HERE.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON SET.
THANKS TO YOU.